welcome back to CBS mornings it has been
an extraordinary week in American
history punctuated by the first ever
arrest of a former U.S president the
unprecedented decision to indict Donald
Trump has further fragmented an already
divided nation while Trump maintains his
innocence and has not been found guilty
we turn to the pass as a point of
reference specifically to examine the
parallels to Richard Nixon's resignation
from Office following the Watergate
scandal take a look at how the past
intersects with the present
we are coming on the air with historic
news
for the first time ever a former
president of the United States has been
indicted the gravity of the moment
splashed on front pages across every
city in this country people should be
held accountable whether they're rich
and Powerful whether their presidents or
former presidents this is legal Voodoo
they're trying to destroy Donald Trump
because they fear him at The Ballot Box
this will only further serve to divide
our country
thank you
the 45th president pleaded not guilty to
34 felony counts of falsifying business
records we cannot and will not normalize
serious criminal conducts the only crime
that I have committed is to fearlessly
defend our nation from those who seek to
destroy it this is not just about Donald
Trump it's a story about the American
presidency being tested in a way where
you haven't really seen since Richard
Nixon
since President Nixon released the new
tape the smoking pistol of the Watergate
evidence have tied it directly to him
events have been rushing toward one
seemingly inevitable conclusion removal
from Office Nixon has chosen to take
that final step himself I shall resign
the presidency vice president for will
be sworn in as president I Gerald R Ford
by taking this action I hope that I will
have hasten to start
of that process of healing which is so
desperately needed in America President
Gerald Ford making a surprise
announcement a full final partner for
former President Nixon during this long
period of delay and potential litigation
ugly passions would again be aroused
and our people would again be polarized
in their opinions it is not the ultimate
fate of Richard Nixon that most concerns
me my concern is the immediate future of
this great country
[Music]
joining us now to see what lessons we
might learn are CBS News Chief political
analyst John Dickerson and presidential
historian Douglas Brinkley good morning
to you both so Doug let me begin with
you uh what parallels do you see between
the state of the country at this time
and Nixon's resignation back in 1973.
well when Watergate was closing in on
Richard Nixon our country had been in a
lot of turmoil mainly the Vietnam War I
mean we had 58 000 dead Americans Untold
wounded
um you know people with a post-traumatic
stress uh syndrome and uh we also had
all the violence of the assassinations
of Martin Luther King and Malcolm X and
Medgar Evers and JFK and RFK so uh there
was a kind of feeling of blood in the
streets that you don't get right now but
when he finally had to resign Nixon in a
Watergate closed in there was like now a
feeling as can democracy withhold this
are we about to topple uh how is our
constitutional system going to work when
we're dealing with the president who so
egregiously abused the law but sure
enough the legal system kicked in and
Spiro Agnew was Char the vice president
Church of Barbary gone while we do talk
a lot about Nixon's famous pardon from
Gerald Ford we maybe don't talk enough
about the jail sentences that Attorney
General John Mitchell had in White House
aides John ehrlichman and H.R Haldeman
had Chuck Colson in the gang so um the
point of history is to remind us that
our own times aren't uniquely oppressive
but but John you know ultimately when
the president did resign a year later
the the fact was that it was the
revelation of The Smoking Gun and the
release of those tapes in the White
House president Trump former president
Trump is facing numerous legal
challenges not just in New York but in
Georgia and also in the January 6th
investigation it's a little different
than the one issue that caused Nixon's
resignation yes and no I mean smoking
guns ain't what they used to be so the
Smoking Gun tape had you know Nixon is
heard obstructing justice well in the
case in the Manhattan district attorney
there's not exactly that there are audio
tapes of Donald Trump uh talking about
the best way to pay off I believe it was
Stormy Daniels but the real Smoking Gun
in the the cluster of legal issues that
were former president Trump faces is his
call to Brad raffensberger Secretary of
State in Georgia basically asking for 11
000 more votes well how was that
received in the modern world it was
sorted bipartisans and so you have a a
party behind president Trump that Nixon
didn't really have he had plenty of
support in his party but he also had
wise men in the party he had Senator
Hugh Scott he had Senator Barry
Goldwater go to him and say you can't
withstand this and what you have now is
you not only have no wise men in the
party going to Donald Trump saying you
can't do this but you also have Fox News
in an entire ecosystem
supporting him and that's a big
difference between then and now in terms
of whether public information that would
have in the past been embarrassing would
is not so embarrassing now at least for
the moment our democracy is supposed to
be the threat that holds this country
together
and some will say it's unraveling day by
day depending on who you ask it's
compromised for different reasons who
Bears the responsibility of acting as
the steward of our democracy it's a
great question in the end it's the
American voter I mean we're responsible
for putting bad politicians into
positions of power not enough people
vote and many people are frivolous about
their vote they'll they'll go with
somebody who's weird or goofy or they
saw on TV that somebody that doesn't
really have chops in the old days we
would elect presidents largely from
their military career how do they
perform in a Leadership Model how did
they rise to becoming a colonel or a
general or how did you perform in law
school were your job in law school is to
defend the Constitution of the United
States right Donald Trump is of neither
of those Traditions he's in nor is he
part of the engineer School of Jimmy
Carter and and Herbert Hoover where
you're using you know empirical data as
your sliggle marker for everything
Trump's a kind of a one-offer he's
always been about himself
self-aggrandizement
um so you know profit for oneself he's
he's about the individual over public
service and the community writ large
speaking of this need to preserve
democracy let's talk about what happened
in the Tennessee Chamber yesterday with
House Republicans expelling two
Democratic lawmakers and black lawmakers
over protesting gun reforms how do you
put this into perspective with history
at large both of you John let's start
with you and what is the impact and the
Ripple effects of that well politics
needs some cartilage it needs some give
it can't be totally brittle so when you
have a situation in here where okay
Republican law makers thought these
these Democrats broke decorum stepped
out of line there are a series of steps
to punish but when you go to the
maximalist when you kick them out
there's that's that's brittle there's no
give when there's no give the only way
the other side gets to respond is by
punching back and so when you lose those
interim steps all you get is response
and response and response and that is
not only you know where that leads right
that leads to violence and it takes us
back to this previous conversation which
is the reason this question of democracy
is so important and the reason faith in
the judicial system is so important is
we are at a moment where more on the
conservative side but on both sides you
have people who think the system isn't
working we've got to affect change
outside of the system through violence
and when you have a system like that you
have no system at all if people take
things into their own hands so if it's
always brittle people think well I can't
get a result from inside the system so I
must go around it and that's what
essentially January 6th is this is a
conversation that obviously needs to be
continued and we will be doing so at
another time John Dickerson Douglas
Brinkley thank you both so much